you do a lot of stand-up on the road
yeah I've been set up on the road for a
long time I've heard and you're not
ashamed about this you like to take
stuff from hotels motels you'll take
what does that mean so tell ya it's like
it's not real yeah about shampoo or TV
yeah no I like decorative pillows hello
I mean the nice ones that yeah anywhere
on the plane you can just happen would
you like oh that's a nice decorative
pillow would you that's it have you ever
stayed at the Hilton yeah you are not
supposed to take the books I love
whenever they have books I'm like this
is obviously you know when they put a
book in a hotel room you thinking okay
well I've got TVs and I got a book you
know let me read a couple of pages and
I'm like oh this is good reading you
know I'll just take your witness okay so
you're taking the books yeah I got a lot
of like you know atlas shrugs I got a
lot of certain books over and over again
wrong with the window comment the way a
lot of Book of Mormons that always
creeps black people out don't do that
where do you and what do you do when you
get these books home you have a book a
fake book library hotel books is like a
whole thing on the website got a lot of
city city you know Cleveland you know
those were the table books all right we
got itwe talked Alito Toledo giant book
Lido
train station got a magnifying glass
look at an ice cream shop you got to
work on your mind work here good it's
way too big this is the Toledo Bailey
don't need a book it's not oh it's
always the smaller cities that have to
use books painting that's what they're
you know what they're doing yeah trust
me know what they're doing
you